[Music]
Demario
returns to face Rachel Lindsay but does
she let him stay I'm really gonna need
you to get the [ __ ] out after being sent
home last week for having a girlfriend
the 30 year old executive recruiter came
crawling back begging for a second
chance on Monday night's episode of The
Bachelorette and Rachel was not having
it when I saw in the gym yesterday that
was a boy I'm looking for a man I'm glad
that you've realized that you should
move forward but I need you to know that
forward isn't that way to the mansion
the word is outside of it thank you
later rachel's besties from nick vials
season of The Bachelor came to help her
choose a man including Raven Gates who
got emotional while giving her a word of
caution about one of her guys last to
the man in the bus who they thought was
gonna trail
in a bowl then carrot
Eric out on the air tonight here's my
reasons I think Eric is just very
serious person I'm shocked but Rachel
ended up giving Eric the coveted group
date Rose and he confronted the men in
this awkward moment it is about me
Kashyap my name is in your mouth it is
about me cuz my name is in your mouth do
you think Eric is there for the right
reasons
let us know over on twitter at ET now
[Music]
you